[Musica]
buongiorno io vorrei partire con un
esperimento li vorrei chiedere di
chiudere gli occhi e di tornare con la
vostra memoria a quando eravate piccoli
alle vostre prime memorie a quando
magari facevate le marachelle a quando
avevate la possibilità di ascoltare i
discorsi dei grandi cosa era importante
cosa non era importante
quali erano i motivi per cui magari
venivate ripresi quelle esperienze di
quella storia che vi portate dietro e la
vostra storia familiare che segna ancora
adesso il modo con cui vivete e il modo
con cui lavorate non necessariamente
allo stesso modo
probabilmente se qualcuno ha avuto
un'educazione molto rigida adesso
rischia di stare dall'altra parte del
pendolo e magari essere molto permissivo
coi suoi figli o magari limita
pedissequamente i genitori
comunque sia quella esperienza li è
un'esperienza che ci segna così tanto da
toccare veramente quello che siamo e
come siamo
e guarda caso ha incrociato tantissimo
anche la mia esperienza personale
professionale
io ho iniziato come manager in
un'azienda multinazionale quindi si
discuteva prima anche con dei colleghi
speaker vedi delle dinamiche molto
regolate e molto normate gestite guidate
quando poi però ho cominciato a lavorare
come consulente con le imprese con gli
imprenditori
ho visto che le regole quelle da manuale
non funzionavano più che c'erano delle
dinamiche molto diverse in gioco e di
cui dovevo tenere conto
mi ricordo ancora che ho cominciato a
scriverne nel mio primo blog nelle mie
prime cose in rete e l'emozione di
quella volta in cui la signora colomba
mi telefona e mi dice abbiamo trovato il
suo articolo in rete lei è un esperto di
queste cose potrebbe venirci ad aiutare
e io ricordo la titubanza la
preoccupazione che aveva da dare in
questa piccola azienda nella provincia
lombarda sicuramente consapevole di non
essere così preparato così esperto come
magari era sembrato a quei signori
eppure quella esperienza li aiutare la
signora colomba la famiglia
a gestire meglio le relazioni passare da
una tensione molto forte al figlio che
dice il papà mamma papà sai che ti
voglio bene vero
ecco quelle sono state delle esperienze
che hanno segnato il modo con cui adesso
lavoro con le imprese e in particolare
con le imprese di famiglia
da allora negli ultimi 10 15 anni
abbiamo sempre lavorato di più abbiamo
creato una rete un gruppo di cose che
insieme lavorano per dedicarsi a queste
cose
decine e decine di casi dopo credo di
poter in qualche modo raccontare cosa ho
imparato da queste esperienze perché
come mi dicono spesso i miei amici
imprenditori quasi seccati e invidiosi
diciamo così della mia possibilità della
mia esperienza mi dicono ma quante cose
sta imparando da noi tantissimo dico e
allora vorrei condividere con voi oggi
proprio questa esperienza
alcune piccole pillole ma credo si
possono essere utili per quello che
siamo e per quello che facciamo nei
nostri diversi contesti ecco allora la
prima pillola potrebbe chiamarsi render
conto una cosa non sempre facile
soprattutto quando siamo alla testa di
un'impresa o la testa di una famiglia
e allora vi vorrei raccontare dell'amico
o mauro un imprenditore che ha avuto la
fortuna di lavorare per cinque anni una
grande multinazionale a fare il manager
per degli anni prima e poi entrare
nell'impresa di famiglia lottare anche
su state delle grandi tensioni con i
cugini e arrivare a governare l'impresa
con i fratelli bellissima realtà molto
affascinante da tanti punti di vista ma
oggi ve la voglio raccontare perché loro
hanno deciso di istituire un trust non
sono neanche un tecnico lascio ad altri
magari raccontare le tecnica nidi di
quello strumento ma quello che mi
interessa è che lui mi ha detto una cosa
per me straordinaria da portarci tutti a
casa dice mi son reso conto quando sono
diventato il capo dell'azienda del
pericolo del rischio di poter fare senza
render conto di come invece scegliere di
mettermi un capo sopra la testa anche se
potevo farne a meno
mi aiutava tirare fuori il meglio di me
a dover essere validato dovrà essere
approvato a dover essere pestato e
questo dice e fa sì che nel momento in
cui magari non sono più all'altezza
di guidare la mia azienda ci sia
qualcuno che deputato che ha la
responsabilità di chiamarmi di dirmi
guarda non è più il tuo momento devi
lasciar perdere perché questo può essere
un grande pericolo quindi il render
conto
me l'ha insegnato anche un'altra persona
un erede di una grande casata una storia
millenaria 1000 1100 anni di storia
incredibile e questo signore mi diceva
gestendo un attività di famiglia molto
grande e legata alle terre legate alle
imprese ad esse collegate
mi diceva io mi rendo conto che tutto
quello che ho non è merito mio è merito
di tutta la generazione le generazioni
che mi hanno seguito la mia grande
responsabilità e non far danno ed
eventualmente a cercare di migliorare
quello che ho ricevuto
ecco questo è il tipo di primo messaggio
che credo di aver ricevuto e non è
sempre scontato neanche nelle nostre
imprese di famiglia
il secondo invece anche fare con gianna
una grande imprenditrice la terza
generazione sta passando alla quarta
generazione
sto alterando i nomi perché non li posso
non li voglio dire ma sono nomi che
sicuramente molti di voi conoscono nella
realtà è questa signora quando io l'ho
incrociata e le ho chiesto ma qual è il
segreto del suo successo del vostro
successo come impresa e come famiglia
lei mi dice noi lottiamo tantissimo
discutiamo ma il focus l'attenzione è
sempre solo sul prodotto sul servizio su
quello che facciamo per i nostri clienti
ecco il concetto di far qualcosa per
altri il concetto di fare qualcosa che
sia di servizio che vada oltre noi
stessi
e allora anche le discussioni cambiano
completamente atmosfera cambiano
completamente gusto che si confligga
però in quel contesto lì me lo conferma
la figlia che si avvicina e si mette a
raccontare del fatto che non è per
niente facile avere a che fare con
quella madre ci si mette a scherzare un
pochettino la nipotina invece diceva che
la nonna la trattava molto molto bene
però la questione era confliggevano così
bene così animatamente perché non era un
confronto tra identità tra echi che si
dovevano in qualche modo a fermare
e proprio il tema del confronto e del
conflitto
e anche la terza grande lezione che
porto a casa penso ad un altro
imprenditrice cristina che mi accoglie
nella sua azienda con la cugina e mi
raccontano un po di questa dinamica
molto bella molto serena in cui c'è
molto dialogo si ascoltano tutti però è
anche chiara la leadership e la guida di
chi ancora tiene al comando l'azienda
con una grandissima serenità e sto
parlando di una grande azienda in questo
caso di grandi numeri e la cosa
straordinaria è che quando io dico
ammirato complimenti questo è un
bellissimo caso che racconterò in
qualche altro contesto
questi mi guardano un po sorprese dicono
ma cosa c'è di strano anzi mi dicono
effettivamente quando ci raccontiamo in
giro
succede che ci dicono questo ma noi non
lo capiamo non capivano quello che
purtroppo succede spesso nelle nostre
imprese le nostre famiglie
succede che non sia facile confrontarsi
per il semplice motivo che caschiamo
tipicamente in due lati in due aree
diverse e non sa né da una parte c'è il
rischio di cadere nella dimensione della
finta armonia della finta cortesia nella
quale si sta insieme senza veramente
dirsi le cose perché costa fatica
dirselo costa fatica a confrontarsi e
dall'altra invece quella nella quale
perché magari c'è troppa confidenza
ci permettiamo di dire cose che poi che
poi rimpiangeremo di aver detto ecco
questa dinamica la capacità di
confrontarsi apertamente in modo
esplicito è un qualcosa che si impara e
che le migliori imprese le migliori
famiglie sono mettere in gioco in modo
estremamente efficace poi un altro
aspetto a che fare con il coinvolgimento
con il coinvolgimento delle altre
persone che qualcuno poi la chiama anche
delega e mi viene in mente il signor
giovanni il presidente di una delle
ultime aziende nelle quali ho lavorato
invece come manager che mi chiama
sottobraccio guarda le persone che
lavorano con lui e con fare molto
affabile mi disse ah che bella gente che
abbiamo qua poi si gira e quasi
sghignazzando ma sai non per altro ma
queste sono quindi la capacità di capire
il limite che abbiamo tutti ma di
metterci in gioco e di far mettere
insomma
le persone che stanno attorno a noi
questa capacità non è per niente facile
perché vuole lasciare delegare vuol dire
permettere a qualcun altro di sbagliare
vuol dire mettersi a fronte di un
rischio che non governiamo più da soli e
di nuovo nelle nostre imprese delle
nostre famiglie tante volte non è così
facile
preferiamo magari i nostri figli
proteggerli e creare quelle condizioni
per cui siano sempre nelle condizioni di
sicurezza peccato che però ci si trovi
poi impreparati ad affrontare le
difficoltà della vita e ultimo punto di
quelli di cui volevo parlare oggi è
l'assunzione di responsabilità io le
vedo nelle piccole cose mi viene in
mente quando pensavo a questo discorso
ad un altro imprenditore che
recentemente mi fa una telefonata ma se
i remi dice luca ho combinato una
cavolata e mi racconta di una
discussione andata oltre le righe e di
avere un po sbottato nei confronti del
fratello e da lì si riparte sicuramente
perché è un anno che ci stiamo lavorando
insieme ed è un anno in cui si cerca di
lavorare perché era delle relazioni un
po più efficaci e un po più sane però
quando io vedo quel tipo di
comportamento quando vedo qualcuno
capace di dire ho sbagliato mi assumo le
responsabilità in quel caso lì anche se
le situazioni sono difficili so che c'è
il seme per poter lavorare e crescere
insieme
altra cosa invece quando ci lamentiamo
degli altri e qui basta pensare a chi
attorno a noi no noi qua dentro ma chi
attorno a noi anzi ieri sera parlavo con
mia moglie dico eccoci qua ci siamo
dentro tutti la questione fondamentale è
capire quando ci stiamo lamentando se
uno sfogo del momento per in qualche
modo scaricare un po di tensione o se
c'è invece un modo nel quale ci togliamo
le responsabilità le lasciamo a qualcun
altro
anche se magari ne avremmo il dovere
ecco quella di nuovo forse una delle
grandi caratteristiche sulle quali credo
dobbiamo riflettere tutti quanti ecco
non per dire allora che le imprese di
famiglia siano delle macchine perfette
anzi si lavora insieme conosco
tantissime situazioni veramente faticose
però a dire che queste due realtà quando
sono combinate insieme
bene sono un esempio a cui guardare con
moltissima attenzione moltissimo
rispetto per un semplice motivo perché
questo è un periodo nel quale non so se
siete d'accordo con me ma io sono
profondamente convinto che rischiamo una
grande solitudine
abbiamo spinto per le libertà
individuali ma non siamo insieme non
siamo comunità qui stiamo parlando già
oggi di tante tematiche che toccano
questi aspetti ma credo sia fondamentale
lavorare su questi che vengono chiamati
da qualcuno corpi intermedi per fare in
modo che siano delle reti di relazioni
tali da sostenerci a vicenda nella buona
e nella cattiva sorte fondamentali per
non andare alla deriva fondamentali per
non avere qualcuno di grande e lontano
si può chiamare stato si può chiamare
istituzioni con cui non si riesce poi
veramente a dialogare
ecco allora da questo punto di vista
qualche noi abbiamo la responsabilità e
il dovere ma anche l'ambizione di
lavorare perché le nostre famiglie le
nostre imprese siano capaci di
integrazione integrazione è una parola
chiave secondo me perché vuol dire
lavorare su due dimensioni a me piace
pensarla in verticale in orizzontale in
verticale c'è un'integrazione di tipo
temporale ne ho parlato un po prima
parlando di quella famiglia di lunga di
lunghe generazioni
ma la questione è che nel tempo io in
qualche modo sono erede e figlio è in
qualche modo sono genitore il creatore e
questo crea due sfide per niente banali
perché come erede come figlio noi siamo
tutti figli su questo siamo d'accordo
giusto ma non è banale faccio un inciso
non previsto ma tempo fa un imprenditore
mi dici perché io sono il creatore
straordinario aveva detto sì il creatore
con l'aci così maiuscola anche si
sentiva adico e lei non deve niente a
nessuno no orgogliosamente mi dice
neanche ai suoi genitori e li si
addolcito subito detto sì quante cose mi
hanno insegnato bene allora partiamo da
questo dal fatto che dobbiamo saper
riconoscere quello che abbiamo ricevuto
e non è facile perché anche qui
rischiamo due cose rischiamo di rimanere
bloccati in quello che abbiamo ricevuto
senza essere capaci di fare quel passo
in più per ammodernare quello che
abbiamo ricevuto per rispetto a un mondo
che cambia che siano valori idee e modi
di gestire le cose ovvero il contrario
di voler dimostrare come in questo caso
che noi possiamo far tutto da zero senza
riconoscerne ente di una tradizione che
ci viene invece donata e poi c'è il tema
invece del genitore che lascia che crea
e la sfida di nuovo alcuni di noi più
magari meno giovani e che abbia o meno
un impresa sanno cosa vuol dire lasciare
andare lasciare andare i figli vuol dire
in qualche modo permettere che la ruota
continui senza sentirti nella necessità
e nell'obbligo di mantenere il presidio
magari perché a volte non hai neanche la
capacità di guardare una prospettiva un
po più a lungo a un po oltre che ti
riguarda e rimane bloccato nella tua
situazione
questo è l'integrazione verticale nel
tempo però c'è anche l'integrazione
orizzontale nello spazio
prima abbiamo parlato dei gradi di
separazione ma molto più fisicamente
provate a pensare cosa si crea quando
una coppia comincia a decidere di fare
un progetto di vita insieme e poi i
figli e poi nel caso delle mie imprese
di famiglia magari si sviluppano
comunità intorno a un lavorare insieme e
via via come cerchi con semplici in
qualche modo queste reti di relazioni si
identificano ci danno in qualche modo un
senso di appartenenza di comunità
straordinario necessario e oggi sempre
più a rischio di non essere coltivato
adeguatamente
ecco che per tante imprese manageriali
adesso lavorare sul concetto di comunità
a lavorare sul concetto di inclusione di
un coinvolgimento di integrazione è
diventato fondamentale e ce l'abbiamo
qui ce l'abbiamo intorno ai nostri
tavoli da pranzo nel giorno a pranzo ea
cena
quindi tornando a noi credo dobbiamo
ricordarci con molta responsabilità del
fatto che non siamo altro che una
generazione che segue la generazione che
ci ha preceduto come diceva un famoso
film
e allora da quel punto di vista abbiamo
una grande responsabilità quella di
saper riguardare e tornare come
nell'esercizio che abbiamo fatto prima
all'esperienza che abbiamo avuto nella
nostra prima infanzia
alle elezioni che ci sono state date ai
valori che abbiamo imparato a far nostri
ma anche a riguardare eventuali limiti
errori dei nostri genitori per crescere
in modo tale da sapere cosa portare con
noi e sapere cosa lasciare per fare in
modo che noi facciamo il nostro piccolo
contributo non solo per mantenere quanto
abbiamo ricevuto ma fare un piccolo
passo avanti nella crescita della nostra
società grazie
[Applauso]